And I think 2 of these answers here are true.
First of all, if you had perfect formal criteria for malware,
the whole thing would fall under Rice's Theorem.
Malware would be a functional property
and we know that functional properties are not decidable,
which in turn means that since the problem is undecidable
that malware detection can never be perfect.
It's not really clear what kind of error you will be making,
so if you will be classifying good software as bad
or bad software as good,
but it can not be perfect,
because if it were perfect, then that would violate Rice's Theorem.
Now NP completeness of course; that is not true for several reasons,
so first of all, running time is
something something that we just can see here,
and secondly, as you've learned,
there are problems that are much worse than problems that lie in NP
so it can also be that malware detection is actually
worse than NP complete.
We just don't know, so this is not a correct answer here.